For this problem, we're going to be implementing some pre-processing rules for SAT
and we're going to be using the same format to represent SAT as in the problem set for Unit 2.
So if you have any questions about that, go ahead and read through this part
or go back and look at the problem set for Unit 2.
Now, what you're going to be doing is writing a function that when given Boolean formula
in the above format, we perform a few data reduction rules and I put the result in set of clauses.
The goal for this is that we're going to give the actual SATs over a much, much smaller--
well, hopefully much smaller Boolean formula than it would ordinarily get
and hopefully, we can improve the performance of SAT in that way.
Now, the data reduction rules we're going to be performing are these four here.
First, if any clause consist of a single variable, we're going to set
that variable so that the clause is satisfied.
So if the clause just consist of x2 for instance, then we'll set it to true,
or is that the clause just consist of not-x2, we're going to set x2 to false,
and that way, we know that x2 has to be that in order for the Boolean formula to be satisfied.
The second one is that if a variable appears just once and it hasn't been set, then we set it
so that the respective clause is satisfied.
The third rule is that we remove all clauses that have become satisfied.
In that way, we just don't have to worry about them anymore in the upcoming SAT solver.
The fourth final rule is that we remove all variables that evaluate to false--
so all variables x that are set to false and all variables not x where x is set to true for instance
that we know are set in that manner.
Now, if this results in an empty clause, then well that means that the input formula
doesn't have any satisfying assignment for that variable, which means
that the Boolean formula itself isn't satisfiable.
So then the function should return the Boolean formula 1, -1, and that is so that
when we give it to a SAT solver, it will always result as unsatisfiable.
Now, the difficult part is implementing rule 2 and rule 4--that's because your function
must perform these data reduction rules excessively until they can't be applied any further.
So after you applied these rules, there might be other clauses for which these rules now apply
that they didn't apply to it before.
Now, you have to be careful if a variable that now appears once has already been set earlier.
If not, then rule 2 may apply, otherwise, it doesn't.
Now, remember that during the course of this pre-processing, we can't change the satisfiability
of the overall formula or else the pre-processing rules aren't really helpful at all.
If a SAT problem is satisfiable, the output of pre-processing also needs to be satisfiable.
So go ahead and implement this function in the space given.